federal law enforcement to uh using
unmarked vehicles to grab
protesters off portland streets let's be
honest
there's a word for this it's black
bagging yeah the story i'm just gonna
i'm not gonna bear the lead on this one
because i think it's hilarious
unmarked vehicles pull up feds jump out
and then walk up to anti-fun just snatch
them up gone
and you know what i mean it's funny to
think because i'm thinking about like
when i was a kid
you know watching like when i was
younger watching v for vendetta or any
of these
you'd imagine that anybody carrying out
these governmental black baggings for
the bad guys
that's a good point no not here 47 days
these people have
been allowed to throw bricks and
molotovs try to burn on a federal
courthouse
yeah that you're not the good guys
you're a bunch of crazy people
and the local government won't enforce
any of these laws so the feds are like
the easiest way to make arrests
is just to be fair they're not showing
up to their homes
you know in the middle of the night
literally putting a black bag over their
head then cracking them with a truncheon
or something
they're waiting until they start walking
away from the courthouse and then come
around when they're by themselves and
arrest them for the riot they just
partook in
exactly but it is still funny to call it
you know them getting black bagged
all right let's read they got an update
here they say in the early hours of july
15th after a night spent
protesting ah peaceful protesting oh
that's
that's what you call when you throw bro
try to crack someone over the head with
a hammer
at the multnomah county justice center
and marco hatfield federal courthouse
mark pettibone and his friend connor
o'shea decided to head home
it had been a calm night compared to
most protesting downtown
okay i am no longer going to use the
word protesting
i'm not going to editorialize the way
they do
they say uh by 2 a.m law enforcement
hadn't used any tear gas
with only a few exceptions both the
portland police bureau and federal law
enforcement officers had stayed out of
sight
a block west of chapman square pettibone
and o'shea bumped into a group of people
who warned them that people in
camouflage were driving around the area
and unmarked many
minivans grabbing people off the street
so that was terrifying to hear pettibone
said
they had barely made it half a block
when an unmarked minivan pulled up in
front of them
i see guys in camo o'shea said four or
five of them pop out
open the door and it was just like os
i don't know who you are or what you
want with us federal law enforcement
officers have been using
unmarked vehicles to drive around
downtown portland
and detain rioters since at least july
14th
personal accounts and multiple videos
posted online show the officers driving
up to people
detaining individuals with no
explanation of why they are being
arrested and driving off
i'ma stop right here and tell you about
one of the most annoying things in the
world to me what's that
there's a there's a really famous viral
video from occupy wall street where the
woman is being arrested
and she's yelling i have not been read
my rights they are not reading me my
rights and i'm like
shut up they don't have to what do you
think is going on
do you think they're going to get in
trouble because they didn't mirandize
you they're not investigating you they
watched you throw the brick
yeah so what people don't get is that um
reading someone's their miranda rights
means they're investigating you
and they need to collect evidence if the
cop literally
watches you throw a brick or swing a
punch or
obstruct a roadway they don't need to
read you your rights you just get
arrested
the evidence is their eyes and their
witness statement i'm an officer
the person swung at me there you go go
to court your word versus their word i
get it
you know see what happens often the
courts side with the cops it's not
perfect
but people seem to think that like no
explanation for why they were being
arrested
they don't have to give you one and
people also think that
they get a phone call it's also not true
either i want my phone call
you don't get one if you're if you're if
you're nice they'll give you one they
can contact your lawyer though
so you can tell them you know i need to
talk to my lawyer well most times if
you're in in like the waiting area like
the in the cell
uh once you're like in the pen there's
there's a they give you 50 cents
and for the most i mean they gave me 50
because i said they didn't give me 50
cents that's all i'm gonna say about
that
but there's a pay phone that that you
can use so i mean you can call someone
collect i'm sure so
i got arrested for skateboarding once
they took my shoelaces off my shoes that
was really annoying because
skater shoelaces are usually frayed and
so like putting them back in as a
nightmare yeah
and uh i said can i make a phone call
and said yep and they walked me over the
phone that was it
and then i couldn't get in touch with
anybody and then i spent the night in
jail and then the judge got really mad
about it later that's a different story
but no like what the the journalists are
writing
that there's no explanation for why
they're being arrested you were just at
a riot
like you're literally outside of a
courthouse rioting they caught you
they're arresting you so they say the
tactic appears to be another escalation
in federal force deployed on portland
city streets
as federal officers and trump have said
they plan to quell nightly protests
outside the federal courthouse
and multnomah county justice center
after uh that have lasted for more than
six weeks wow yeah maybe they got to do
something okay
let me let me ask you what's the
alternative should the feds just like
plow in with cow catchers and just
barrel through these these rioters
are they going to run out full speed and
just start slamming build to the ground
it's a conflict they're trying to avoid
right and this seems to be a
more peaceful less violent way to
actually grab people been riding i'm
going to show you this check this out
acting secretary wolf condemns the
rampant long-lasting violence in
portland
the city of portland has been under
siege for 47 straight days by a violent
mob
while local political leaders refuse to
restore order to protect their city
each night lawless anarchists i take i
take
issue with that term destroy and
desecrate property including the federal
courthouse
and attack the brave law enforcement
officers protecting it
you know what man you know what would
happen if the rioters just did just went
home
what nothing would happen yeah nothing
the law enforcement officers would be
sitting in the office
inside the building probably talking
about the latest episode of
i don't know is anybody talking about
westworld anymore that show's kind of
got off the rails
no what does anybody watching it came
out and and then it went
yeah like really fell fast yeah what is
that what is it
whatever you get the point they're gonna
be they're gonna be complaining about
how there's no sports
they're gonna be sitting there being
like man i can't wait for baseball to
come back to come back next weekend next
week a week from today
yeah that's what uh it's been reported
by some outlets
but nothing would happen the federal law
enforcement aren't marching through the
street and targeting people
but now they're trying to make it seem
like that because they're literally
attacking a courthouse trying to burn it
down
right check out this so uh well and most
people are saying
well the riots are over no one's rioting
anymore
when this has been going on for six
weeks go ahead yeah they say petabone
did not escape the federal officers
i am basically tossed into the van and i
had my beanie pulled over my face
this is a violation of human rights i am
on the side of the protest
i'm kidding beanie lives matter they
they pulled his beanie down
how dare the hell rum so i pulled my
beanie down on my face so i couldn't see
and they held my hands over my head
weird pettibone and o'shea bull said
they couldn't think of anything they
might have done to end up targeted by
law enforcement
they attended violent riots regularly
but they said they aren't instigators
they don't spray paint buildings shine
laser pointers at officers or do
anything else other than attend riots
which law enforcement have regularly
deemed unlawful assemblies
yes because they're riots have you seen
the videos yeah they're crazy they're
just burning things
they are not peaceful protests yeah that
is what is protected
thank you some guy on twitter this is a
great story let's read
blind is blinded by his hat in an
unmarked minivan full of armed people
dressed in camouflage and body armor who
hadn't identified themselves
pettibone said he was driven around
downtown before being unloaded inside
the building
he wouldn't learn until after his
release that he had been inside the
federal courthouse wow that's amazing
so these people leave the courthouse
during the riot the van pulls up
snatches and brings them back
that's crazy yeah it is it was basically
a process of facing many walls and
corners
as they patted me down and took my
picture and rummaged through my
belongings
one of them said this is a whole lot of
nothing pedophone said he was put into a
cell
soon after two officers came in to read
him his miranda rights wow that sounds
like they're investigating him for
probably
probably conspiracy or something yeah
maybe they didn't tell him why he was
being arrested
he said they asked him if he wanted to
waive his rights and answer some
questions but
pettibone declined and said he wanted a
lawyer the interview was terminated
and about 90 minutes later he was
released he said he did not receive any
paperwork citation or record of his
arrest
and i didn't did you do they give you i
didn't give anything they gave me my
skateboards have a nice day
and i walked out i yeah i don't want to
expect so much
oh i just i cannot confirm nor deny
i just happened to be wearing black on a
sidewalk in downtown portland at the
time
and that apparently has grounds for
detaining me you know what man spare me
the bs
i don't buy it no i've seen the videos
of the ongoing
attacks and you know what if you
show up to an event where you know for
47 days they're rioting violently and
they plan to do so
and they tell you to wear all black to
help them
yeah you'll be arrested for being an
accomplice yep
now you may not you know the charges
might not stick you might get away with
it
but they specifically say we're all
black on purpose so that they can get
away with crimes
if you shield them you're helping them
you're an accomplice
they say in a statement the u.s marshal
service declined to comment on the
practice of using unmarked vehicles
but said their officers had uh had not
arrested pettibone
all united states marshals service
arrestees have public records of arrest
documenting their charges our agency did
not arrest or detain mark james
pettibone now that's weird
yeah it is department of homeland
security officials did not immediately
respond to a request for comment
it's like stop and frisk meets
guantanamo bay said attorney juan chavez
director of the civil rights project at
the oregon justice resource center
chavez has worked on litigation
surrounding the weeks of protest the
weeks of rioting
yeah okay he called the arrests
terrifying you have laws regarding
probable cause that can lead to arrests
it sounds more like abduction it sounds
like they're kidnapping people off the
streets let me ask you something
if you got arrested because you are a
riot and they decided not to charge you
when they released you would you be
complaining about it
no i'd be stoked i was in i was in dc
during the inaugural
riots donald trump was being inaugurated
rioting broke out
the police cuddled the entire crowd
that's what it's called and i was
trapped inside
they had told me i was arrested
eventually we talked about it before
yeah i was able to get out by just
saying i'm pressed and then eventually
they pulled out the press
and i was very happy to have been
released yeah that's about it
i'm not complaining i understand why
they're arresting everybody they're
trying to politicize it all though
that's
that makes sense that they're
complaining they're trying to as we said
earlier
it's a trap they wanted trump to pull
the trigger so they can
use it against him look he's the
authorita authoritarian
you know president we always thought he
was like this proves that c
occupying army i was i was out
peacefully protesting and i was waving a
sign
and then the the the bad men wearing
wearing all camouflage came and and they
took me kidnapped me
so what you're saying well i pulled my
beanie down i pulled my beanie down in
the car
now that i can understand that is a
outrageous violence i'm kidding
let me let me fix this you were at a
violent riot
the riots have been going on for six
weeks and they
invest they were investigating you and
you got temporarily detained
you're lucky that's that's that that's
the the released
and then really yeah he wasn't in for
for days it was like 90 minutes yeah
under two hours are you serious and
you're complaining i got to spend
something like
12 hours in jail yes because i was
skateboarding in chicago
i also spent the night in jail it's not
it's not a fun thing to do
it was cold it was bright it was on a
concrete slab because i was
skateboarding someone really nice
actually gave me some
toilet paper to use as a pillow you know
when i was uh when i got arrested this
was in downtown chicago the jail was
just a big concrete block
that you could sit on you could sit and
land a con i used i think i think i used
my shoe as a pillow
there was no contact with anyone else
and there was people there were people
screaming
just like the whole night screaming
sleeping with the lights on cold with
like on a concrete slab
wasn't fun i had no idea what time it
was how long i'd been in there there's
no windows or anything and then finally
they came let me out
and they handed me my board back and
they said something about like uh here's
you have a court date whatever when i
went to court the judge was like
what is this get out of my courtroom he
was like he was really angry like he was
really offended i think yeah but they
showed up they were trying to prosecute
like the the
people who their security guards at a
federal building who want to be arrested
actually showed up and the judge was
like are you kidding me right
some some 19-year-old kid is
skateboarding you know
on your building sidewalk yeah don't you
have better things to do
huh i'll tell you go do better things i
didn't cry about it
i got i got released and then i was like
i don't know
now what and then i went to court i was
just sitting there and i was like i
don't know now what
and they told me to leave and that was
it you know
what what can you do these people are
like oh i've been arrested
no no i wasn't arrested all right i was
released after
90 minutes they didn't even arrest me
you know you know what it is
maybe the maybe the real reason he's
upset is because he's not good enough to
be arrested
why aren't you arresting me hey wait
were you arresting him come on i've been
riding here all month
are we are we gonna show the video of
them taking him
do we have it is it on there i don't
think it's on there oh really yeah i
don't think it's i don't think they
actually have it oh i mean i've
i've got it over here there's a bunch is
it is it of that specific i don't know
who it is
but it is it is two people walking up to
a guy wearing all black and taking him
in do you have it did you transfer
i mean i have it right here i could i
could give it to you hold on yeah and
then
while you do that i'll pull up this
video shows protesters get shipment of
bats before brooklyn bridge brawl
interesting okay they say surveillance
video from outside city hall appears
show protesters protesters receiving a
small shipment of bats before anti-cop
activists clashed with officers
on the brooklyn bridge the delivery was
made by a car parked on the street near
city hall
one man retrieving six bats of the trunk
police say
the bats were delivered so the anti-cop
activists could confront a unity rally
proceeding over the brooklyn bridge into
manhattan the unity rally included
clergy law enforcement and community
activists
it's unclear if the city hall protesters
used the bats in the wild brooklyn
bridge brawl
before opposing protesters so i guess
you've seen the footage of the cops who
have been bashed over the head yeah it's
messed up
and it was the same cop that was uh
kneeling kneeling with the protesters
trying to like
i i don't want to use the word appease
you know but to
to show solidarity i guess with them you
know and so look i'm i'm here with you
guys i'll kneel with you
and then he's he's the one of the people
that got back beat over the head
it was like you don't care about so we
got the uh check us out we got
one of the one of the black bag videos
it's uh it's so nice watching some
movement on arresting these antifa
people looks like military or homeland
security units
listen uh listen to the woman ask use
your words yeah what are you doing
use your words what are you doing
use your words what are you doing we got
you friend
use your words
what is going on look how he's dressed
[Music]
nothing happened you just violated their
rights
oh shut up notice the individual look
look how they're dressed he's got a bag
potentially something in it but he's
wearing a helmet right
what is the what is the old saying the
protesters like to say
why are you in riot gear i don't see a
riot here
hmm so i'll say the same thing to this
dude why are you in riot gear bro
right were you coming expecting a riot
looks like you were
looks like there's been unrest and
rioting for 47 days and you were down
there with protective gear for some
reason
that's not necessarily a crime or
anything like that but they
it seems like they're investigating
these people he probably matched a
description guess what they can arrest
you
yeah we'll not arrest they can detain
and investigate he didn't want to uh
answer any questions they cut him loose
there you go
don't don't go to riots now this this
isn't uh we don't know
exactly if that's who we were talking
about before um i don't remember the
name of the man that uh
we were talking about yeah the other
article this is just
an example of uh one of these minivans
showing up and
and taking this person away so you know
what man
you want to engage in this kind of stuff
i'm not surprised it's going to happen
what am i supposed to say
right you know i i was making the joke
earl earlier about you know when i was a
kid you'd never actually expect the guys
jumping out in the minivan and snatching
someone off the street to be the good
guys right
but in this instance if their choice is
to you know fire a bean bag which hit
somebody in the face and cracks their
skull
or to just drive up in a car and pick
one person up and start investigating
which would you pick yeah what would you
have a non-lethal action always
what would you have us do to stop 47
days of riding when the arrests don't
work
and when they keep releasing these
people without indictment what
what what do you do so i think this is
the the more peaceful option
yeah you wait until they start walking
away from the courthouse then then you
pull up when they're alone and you walk
out you arrest them
and they didn't even get arrested they
got investigated detained yeah that's
the worst and released
in 90 minutes it's ridiculous yeah
and they they make it a big story
because it fits their narrative that
they're oppressed
right exactly yeah you don't you know
it's so it's so crazy you don't get to
throw a brick through a window start a
fire and then go help help i'm being
repressed when the police come and say
you're under arrest
it should be a song thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast irl
podcast we do the show live
monday through friday at 8pm if you want
to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you